Danny Masterson is an actor who most
people haven't thought about for a long
time if at all by all accounts his
career peaked all the way back in 2006
with the conclusion of the sitcom That
70s Show but a few years ago all of a
sudden Masterson's name was everywhere
that's because in March of 2017 the year
that the hashtag metoo movement began in
Earnest Masterson was accused of sexual
assault by three women in response
without waiting for a trial Netflix
summarily fired Masterson from his role
as a series regular on one of their
shows and three years later in the
summer of 2020 Masterson was formally
charged with three rapes in Los Angeles
a jurisdiction that of course believes
all women prosecutors said that one rape
occurred in 2001 another in early 2003
and a third in late 2003. now right off
the bat the timeline raises some obvious
questions for one thing how is it
possible to prove a rape Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt 20 years after the fact
in the absence of any physical evidence
of violence or drugging now you might
think that the accusers must have had
airtight stories
but that's not true in this case in fact
one of the accusers previously told
authorities that Masterson had not raped
her she says that she only realized
years later that she was raped she
originally thought it was consensual and
then years after the fact changed her
mind
all this explains why late last year the
jury deadlocked there was a mistrial
according to the foreman on that jury
they were leaning towards acquittal on
every count and he said that the reason
for that is that they found the stories
from the accusers to be inconsistent
contradictory and implausible
but then just a couple of weeks later a
couple of weeks ago I should say as you
might have heard Masterson was put on
trial again and this time around the
judge changed the rules the judge
allowed testimony that Masterson had
drugged his victims even though there
was no physical evidence of that in the
first trial the prosecution was only
allowed to describe the condition
of the of the accusers after they
consumed alcoholic beverages that
Masterson gave them describing them as
woozy and disoriented they were not
allowed to directly claim that the women
were drugged because there was no
evidence of that there was no evidence
that their wooziness was the result of
anything more than the alcohol they were
drinking but in the second trial that
kind of caution was thrown to the wind
and again without any actual evidence
Masterson was accused of drugging his
alleged victims and that apparently did
the trick Masterson was convicted after
after the retrial and he was sentenced
to 30 years in prison
now you don't have to like Danny
Masterson or know who he is or believe
he's innocent to understand the
implications of what happened to him
Danny Masterson's case is proof that
even in 2023 years after the hashtag
metoo hysteria has faded physical
evidence of wrongdoing is not required
to convict someone of rape and destroy
their life neither is timely reporting
or even a consistent story from the
alleged victims
all you need is a story
Danny Masterson's case demonstrates that
for one thing that means that our
judicial system isn't exactly
functioning the way that it should but
you already knew that what Masterson's
case also means if you think about it
from the perspective of the government
is that accusations of rape are
trivially easy to use as political
weapons Masterson's own case doesn't
appear to be political but it shows how
easy it could be and has been to use a
rape accusation to achieve a political
end
you'd hate to think that false stories
about rape could ever be deployed for
these kinds of purposes to ruin the
lives of influential voices who
challenge the people in power but
increasingly that's exactly what's
happening
a couple of days ago the influential
comedian and commentator Russell Brand
uploaded this video explaining that he's
now being accused of sexual assault by
multiple media Outlets watch
hello there you Awakening wonders now
this isn't the usual type of video we
make on this channel where we critique
attack and undermine the news in all its
corruption because in this story I am
the news I've received two extremely
disturbing letters or a letter and an
email one from a mainstream media TV
company one from a newspaper listing a
Litany of extremely egregious and
aggressive attacks as well as some
pretty stupid stuffs like uh my
community Festival should be stopped
that I shouldn't be able to attack
mainstream media narratives on this
channel but amidst this Litany of
astonishing rather bar Rock attacks are
some very serious allegations that I
absolutely refute
these allegations pertain to the time
when I was working in the mainstream
when I was in the newspapers all the
time when I was in the movies and as
I've written about extensively in my
books I was very very promiscuous now
during that time of promiscuity the
relationships I had were absolutely
always consensual I was always
transparent about that then almost too
transparent and I'm being transparent
about it now as well and to see that
transparency metastasized into something
criminal that I absolutely deny makes me
question is there another agenda at Play
now we don't know exactly who these
women are who are accusing brand of
sexual misconduct but the daily wire
reports that these incidents supposedly
occur between 2006 and 2013. so like the
accusations against Masterson these
sexual assaults allegedly occurred at
the height of Russell Brand's mainstream
Fame and yet strangely enough without
any explanation these accusations are
only coming up now many years later
the whole lengthy story with all the
allegations is laid out in a Channel 4
documentary and in the times and you can
read the details for yourself if you pay
for a subscription to the times that's
because they launched a series of
allegations against brand and then
immediately put the accusations behind a
paywall
it's too early to say right now exactly
what's really happening or what really
happened all those years ago we can't
prejudge this case of course but one
thing we can say with certainty is that
Russell Brand is a far bigger threat to
this nation's power Brokers now than he
was at the height of his Fame back when
he was married to Katy Perry and
starring in Hollywood films and living
as he said a very promiscuous lifestyle
anybody who watches Russell Brand's
videos knows all that but really Brands
turn into unorthodox thinking began sort
of slowly roughly a decade ago it was in
2013 that brand was ejected from the GQ
awards show for noting in his acceptance
speech that a sponsor of the show had
previously made uniforms for the Nazis
from that point on bran became something
of a pariah in the entertainment
industry and in recent years his views
have only become more intolerable to
those in power
now in particular
Russell Brand has heterodox views on the
Integrity of U.S elections he doesn't
toe the line on January 6th and perhaps
most consequentially he's
extraordinarily critical of big Pharma
he doesn't believe as the rest of the
corporate media does that you should
reflexively trust the pharmaceutical
companies and just ingest every drug
they give you
and he's made his views on this subject
known here here he was with Bill Maher
recently for example watch
well yes I'll respect for you in your
show I've bought some facts would you
please
not the place
I love that I wouldn't have mentioned it
I'm English and you know that politeness
is our fundamental religion
yeah if they're inconvenient to you I'll
stop saying them the pandemic created at
least 40 new far big Pharma billionaires
pharmaceutical corporations like moderna
and Pfizer made a thousand dollars of
profit every second from the covid-19
vaccine more than two-thirds of Congress
received campaign funding from
pharmaceutical companies in the 2020
election Pfizer chairman Albert baller
told Time magazine in July 2020 that his
company was developing a covered vaccine
for the good of humanity not for money
and of course Pfizer made a hundred
billion dollars in profit in 2022. and
may I just mentioned that finally and
these are this is also a fact that you
the American public funded the
development of that the German Republic
funded the bio and Tech vaccine when it
came to the profits they took the
profits when it came to the funding you
paid for the funding all I'm querying is
this yes is if you have an economic
system in which pharmaceutical companies
benefit hugely from medical emergencies
where a military industrial complex
benefits from war where an energy
companies benefit from energy crisis you
are going to generate states of
Perpetual crisis for the interests of
Ordinary People well yes and separate
from the interests of the elite
now that's not something you're supposed
to say out loud it's all true of course
but you're questioning you're calling it
a question uh some of the most powerful
people and institutions in the country
it's hard not to notice that people who
say things like this out loud tend to
get in a lot of trouble you might
remember what happened to a James
O'Keefe's project Veritas O'Keefe
exposed a high-ranking Pfizer executive
admitting among other things that his
company is conducting secret gain of
function research on coronaviruses right
here in the United States the Pfizer
executive then freaked out when he
realized he was on camera what happened
next the Pfizer executive was not
publicly fired instead O'Keefe was
publicly fired funny how that works out
is Russell Brand being targeted for the
same reasons already his agent and
several organizations have cut ties with
him so he appears to be on the same
trajectory
to be clear we don't know whether
Russell Brand is innocent or guilty just
like we don't know if Danny Masterson is
innocent or guilty but
there are obvious reasons to doubt
stories that surface several years after
the fact especially when Witnesses
contradict the narratives as you just
heard that's what Russell Brand says is
happening as you might know I'm uh I'm a
huge fan of our friends of geniusella
genu sales products Sunspot brown spots
discoloration and even red inflamed
patches all disappear in front of your
very eyes and here's the genus how
amazing guarantee you'll see results on
day one or your money back if you want
to feel better about your own skin take
advantage of geniusell's most popular
package which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic genucel bags
and puffiness treatment and immediate
effects all at about 70 off so you can
try the best skin care in the world for
yourself completely risk-free it's
simple go to genyourself.com Walsh YT
start looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spots bags and puffiness under the eyes
and crow's feet at genucel.com Walsh YT
that's geniusella.com Walsh YT one woman
just posted a video claim meaning that
British media reached out to her for a
documentary on Russell Brand presumably
the channel 4 documentary but they
didn't use her story because she said
that her interactions with brand were
all consensual and positive watch
I actually know who this is about and I
have the receipts I was contacted in
June by a journalist regarding a video I
made about a certain celebrity and a
weekend that we shared together the
video is kind of viral uh it's on my
page somewhere if you want to go see it
and that certain somebody was as most of
you will be aware Mr brand they weren't
going to use my story because it didn't
fit the narrative for the documentary
because he wasn't an old to me but here
are some of the messages obviously I
will take out the person's name and
stuff
we had a phone call she contacted me for
more information and I didn't contact
her back because I kind of felt like it
would be mean anyway there you go put
your bets on it's a documentary about
the one and only Mr Russell Brand and
just a fun fact astrology wise the lunar
nodes of Destiny have shifted into Aries
right on top of his Mars and moon
Written in the Stars baby okay bye
okay well that's interesting not the
astrology stuff but the stuff before
that if you were making a film about
sexual assault accusations against the
famous person from several years ago
you'd think you'd want to gather all of
the relevant evidence and present it but
if you want to create a hit piece you'd
ignore the witnesses that you don't like
and present the ones with the most
salacious stories possible and it
appears based on that video that's
exactly what's happening now Brands
critics will argue that just because the
woman in that video says she wasn't
raped that doesn't mean that other women
weren't raped a rapist isn't going to
abuse every woman he comes across
presumably but the point is that if
you're dredging up accusations from
years and years ago and you have no
evidence that anything happened
then all you can do is theorize and make
assumptions the best you'll end up with
is an educated guess
but it's not possible to make an
educated guess without being presented
the full picture the full story of what
sort of person they accused was at the
time when he allegedly did the things he
was accused of doing
if you're a journalist only presenting
parts of the picture and leaving out the
parts that don't lead to your preferred
conclusion then you're not a journalist
at all you are an assassin looking to
kill someone's reputation
we've seen this time and time again
the moment somebody becomes a threat to
the establishment the accusations of
sexual assault materialize from thin air
it is it is impossible not to notice
this trend we see it at the Supreme
Court with Clarence Thomas and Brett
Kavanaugh we saw it with Trump I mean he
was a billionaire celebrity Playboy but
was never accused of sexual assault
until he became a threat to the left
even Tucker Carlson it's easy to forget
was accused of sexual misconduct at the
height of his show success those
accusations were
absurd on their face and never went
anywhere but that's not how these things
usually play out whatever you think of
Dave Portnoy the accusations against him
follow a similar pattern Portnoy isn't
really political and I certainly
wouldn't call him a conservative and I
don't think he calls himself a
conservative but during covid he did
something you're not supposed to do he
noticed that the government's lockdowns
were destroying small businesses and
that the FED so-called pandemic Relief
Fund wasn't covering these businesses
losses not even close support no way
through his company raised millions of
dollars for businesses as long as they
kept employing their workers throughout
the lockdowns and that got the attention
of the government in in not a good way
you know a year later he was accused of
can you guess sexual misconduct
the Brash founder of website and Media
company Barstool Sports is firing back
today at alarming allegations of sexual
misconduct a report by Business Insider
details alleged sexual encounters
between Dave Portnoy and two women one
of the alleged victims says she was
literally screaming in pain Portnoy
calls the article a hit piece and denies
the allegations NBC News is not
independently verified these allegations
NBC News didn't verify the accusations
but of course they're happy to repeat
them it's a familiar story and it's the
inevitable result of believe all women
this is the legacy of hashtag me too
you can either do what you're told or
the most powerful forces in the country
will try to destroy you
with respect to Russell Brand
I think we're left with two
possibilities
okay and neither of them are good
one is that brand is an innocent man
being smeared by the mainstream media I
don't know for sure if this is what's
happening here or not nobody can know I
wasn't there I just don't know but but
that's how the game is played just by
printing the accusation you have forever
tarnished a man's reputation whether
it's true or not after all the most that
even his most Ardent Defenders can say
his most Ardent Defenders the most they
can say
is that he's probably not a rapist
and this is what makes the media's
willingness to print accusations no
matter how credible or incredible they
are so Sinister they know that the
accusations will devastate a man's life
and reputation even if there's no
evidence to support them even if they're
debunked and refuted even if even if
positive evidence can be presented
proving that the thing didn't happen
just the very fact the accusation was
ever made is already enough to
permanently damage someone
but there's another possibility here
the other possibility is that the
media's claims are true
in that scenario brand is a known serial
rapist who victimized multiple women for
years during the height of his Fame
that's what the media is saying
it's what they want us to believe okay
that's their narrative
but for the sake of argument let's let's
let's let's uh
go with that for a moment with that
narrative well here's the thing about it
if that's true it makes the media
arguably even worse than if they were
inventing these claims out of whole
cloth
because it means that they left brand
alone they allowed him to continue
abusing women for years and years until
he said things they disagreed with
remember part of this whole story is
that this was a an Open Secret everyone
knew this was happening so the media is
saying well if everyone knew what the
media must have known it
and it didn't say anything they didn't
report on it
until the moment
that he became inconvenient to them
both of those options are horrific in
their own way
and in either case
it's clear who the real enemy is
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there